that's kind of you thank you if I may I
thought you well I'm not sure how to put
this into words I'm actually quite
embarrassed to say it but I was thinking
about what I do when I'm healing you
know what usually goes through my mind
it helps when I think and I think about
what think about what meifa you know I'm
asking that question rhetorically
because come on we all know what meifa
was about to say and if you're not sure
here's a little insight MIFA the zora
princess turned champion who's currently
sleeping with the fishes but that one's
had her heart completely stolen by the
sharp blue eyes of our one and only hero
like if you're not convinced that's the
truth for some reason there are hints
dropped in basically every single memory
or cutscene we see her/him that allude
pretty strongly to her feelings towards
link and her brother the dashing Prince
sidon confirms it so that the old
grouchy's or a guy would calm down with
his highly in hatred but anyway back to
the cutscene I just showed you it's
pretty clear that meifa was about to
reveal that the secret to unlocking or
using her quite frankly overpowered
healing abilities lies in her devoted
feelings for link which is just so sweet
but do you recall how Zelda's powers are
unlocked let's listen to what Cass the
songbird has to say about it the
princess's love for her fallen Knight
awakens her power and within the castle
the calamity is forced to cower did that
first part sound a little familiar
let's see me FFA's power activates when
she thinks about her feelings for link
and Zelda's powers activated when she
realized how much she loved link her
fallen Knight the two princesses have
more in common than just both being
princesses they both love
but while neva was able to realize this
and be honest with herself in order to
control her powers zelda tragically
unlocked them too late after all the
other champions had died after her
father had died after Hyrule was in
flames and countless other citizens had
died and after link had died my baby and
yes well we do know that in the end it
all works out you know give or take a
hundred year time lapse I can't help but
think about the last memory of all of
the champions alive together since zelda
hadn't discovered her powers yet and
meifa was about to tell her the secret
to unlocking them what if she did if
they had 10 more seconds before again
and woke up would the events of a
hundred years ago have changed if meifa
finished her sentence would she be alive
today let's talk about it
so real quick before we begin make sure
you're subscribed to the channel if
you're not already for all the awesome
Nintendo stuff that happens right here
on mask Nintendo bandit and drop a like
when you're done watching if you enjoyed
anyway the first thing we need to ask is
what Zelda's awakened power 100 years
ago be enough to defeat calamity Ganon
the first instinct would probably be to
say yeah it would but we need a double
check if all the pieces are in place for
Ganon's demise because as we've seen
over the course of a hundred years zelda
can't do it alone so what does it take
as far as we can tell calamity Ganon has
been beaten twice once in the ten
thousand year old legend when it took
the combined forces of Hyrule the
sheikah technologies divine beasts and
their champions the princess and the
hero wielding the blade of Evil's Bane
and the second time when all it really
took was the princess and the hero I
mean don't get me wrong having the
divine beasts around to laser-beam Ganon
down to half health before link even
begins sparring with him is very useful
but ultimately not necessary to defeat
Ganon Leng can do it either way the real
victory comes from Zelda's power being
literally shot into Ganon from arrows of
light wielded by the hero clearly the
common denominator and only
requirements to defeating calamity Ganon
is the presence and power of both
princess and chosen hero and if zelda
were to have received me FFA's advice
and awoken the power within her the only
remaining question is would our link of
a hundred years ago be up to the
challenge of fighting alongside her and
best calamity Ganon in physical combat
admittedly it's a little hard to tell
just how physically adept link was
before his slumber we constantly see
memories and stories of his combat
prowess and we also know that he
actually found and drew the Master Sword
all by himself
meaning pre slumber link was definitely
no weakling by any stretch of the
imagination
however we also see him fall in combat
before even reaching calamity Ganon
because he had battled too many Guardian
stalkers a feat that current link really
doesn't have that much of an issue with
especially once he's retrieved the
Master Sword and by the way if you'd
like my theory on what may have happened
to make link fall in combat here and
trust me it's not what you're thinking
feel free to click the link in the
description below or the button on the
top right at the screen to check out my
other theory on the matter but anyway I
think it's pretty safe to say that
modern-day post slumber link is at the
peak of his power especially when he's
adventured for a while and has raised
his stamina health armor and weaponry
it's also possible that maybe other
weapons besides the Master Sword were
just not a part of his weaponry arsenal
100 years ago as an enlisted knight of
hyrule meaning his overall combined
power level may just not have been as
high as current links is but fortunately
for him Zelda at full power uh can do
stuff like this
so I'm thinking that yeah if link had
the Master Sword and Zelda had her
powers a hundred years ago
calamity Ganon would have been defeated
right there and then possibly preventing
the sacking of hyrule castle and even
the death of Zelda's father but for as
happy of an ending as that sounds I
unfortunately have to point out one last
tragic detail you see if meifa told
Zelda how to accurately unlock her
powers and Zelda and link make a mad
dash to Hyrule Castle to confront Ganon
that doesn't change the fact that the
champions were also hurrying to
their own divine beasts where we know
the gans were already waiting in ambush
each champion that includes me feh was
completely alone and killed by the
Ganon's that were haunting their divine
beasts far away from any help
far away from Zelda and link this means
that me FFA's death was probably
inevitable due to the deadly trap set by
calamity Ganon unless Zelda immediately
knew to warp Lincoln herself to Ganon's
location and they were able to defeat
him before the champions reached the
divine beasts but that's not very likely
either way if meifa and the other
champions could have been saved or were
destined to die little did she know that
those few precious final words she was
about to say to Princess Zelda would
have saved the world and countless lives
from a monstrous calamity if she only
had ten more seconds and that is my
what-if theory on me feh and the
salvation of Hyrule what did you guys
think could Zelda have gone super saiyan
and defeated Ganon alongside the hero
100 years ago or was it a loss either
way let me know in the comments below
hey guys thank you so much for watching
this shorter theory video as always huge
thanks to my supporters and welcome to
my new ones
say hello to Joanna Shannon she's ooh
bro and kya you guys inspire me more
than you'll ever know and I can't thank
you enough
enjoy your benefits guys if you're
interested in joining the channel
getting some epic rewards and custom
emoji and badges click that join button
or follow the link in the description
below also down there are links to my
social media pages so drop on by and say
hi that's all I've got for this one so
do me a favor and have a great rest of
your day
this is Mastana Banat signing out
[Music]